c'est une manifestation pour le moins
originale ce lundi en plein centre de
lyon face à l'hôtel de ville
des agriculteurs ont organisé une
dégustation de viande
opération coup de poing contre la mesure
du maire europe ecologie les verts
grégory douce et de retirer la viande
des cantines scolaires
si la mairie de lyon justifie cette
décision par la situation sanitaire
actuelle
cette mesure est jugée dangereuse pour
la santé des enfants
pour françois valerette président de la
coordination rurale de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
en effet le fait que le menu unique puis
simplifier la gestion des flux est
compréhensible mais le fait que le menu
sans viande fluidifie le trafic ne l'est
pas du tout c'est une aberration
il s'agit en fait d'une décision
politique afin d'imposer une idéologie
et instiller dans l'esprit de nos
enfants dès leur plus jeune âge
l'idée que nos agriculteurs sont les
ennemis de la société trop c'est trop
pour les éleveurs français
ces derniers estiment que cette mesure
est discriminatoire en effet bon nombre
de parents choisissent de mettre leurs
enfants à la cantine pour leur permettre
de manger de la viande des agriculteurs
qui partage aujourd'hui leur lassitude
on n'a pas le droit d'imposer d'imposer
aux gens ces idées de force notamment
d'interdire la viande dans les cantines
soit disant part à cause du coroner
virus à une fois l'élevage qui visé par
rapport à ce que disent aujourd'hui une
certaine minorité
dans les rangs des français c'est une
minorité mais qui est que vous reprenez
vous médias je suis désolé à grande
audience et malheureusement c'est encore
un coup un peu plus confiants sur la
tête
un menu unique sans viande également
décrié par des parents d'élèves
certains d'entre eux ont l'intention de
déposer un référé devant le tribunal
administratif de lyon d'ici ce vendredi
il souhaite faire suspendre cette mesure
l'audience devrait avoir lieu d'ici une
quinzaine de jours